- That's disgusting!
- No it's not at all disgusting.
- It's....oh my god.
- I didn't find it disgusting.
It looks the best, it tastes the worst!
(bouncy guitar)
- Today we are going
to be trying out offal.
- Which is like different cuts of meat.
- Are we looking forward to it?
- No.
- I'm just hoping to not throw up.
- It's called gurda.
Which I believe are kidneys.
- I hope there are no stones.
- It looks exactly like mushrooms.
- It's actually quite nice.
- Yeah I like it.
- Go on, it's not that bad.
- Mmhmm!
- I'm getting a weird aftertaste now.
- It's not that bad.
- I need mouthwash.
- So in all fairness
this looks disgusting.
- Oh shit it's the entire tongue.
- And there is something bony at the end.
I have no idea what the fuck that is.
- What kind of tongue has a bone, man?
- I feel like Hannibal Lector right now.
- He does eat tongue.
- Not picturing the tongue will help.
- Wow you really like it.
- It's really nice dude!
- I guess I don't have a heart.
- How can you be so
- [both] heartless!
- I actually like it.
- And the aftertaste is .....
- I want to spit this out right now.
- This is actually like
having rubber dipped
in a goddamn masala.
- So it's technically boobs.
- I never thought that the
first time I'd be motorboating
someone it would be a goat.
- I didn't think boobs had bones.
- Why does it not have a bone in it?
- No that's not a bone
that's a wane I think.
- I don't think my mom's
going to forgive me .
Sorry Mom.
- Cheers.
- Like there seems to be just
a surplus of oil all over.
- I don't know, it goes into
your mouth and just dissolve?
- It was really creamy, flavored well.
- I don't like the texture
but the taste is pretty nice.
- If I didn't know what
it was I'd be like,
" Wow that just melt in my mouth."
- Maybe I'll become more
intelligent after this.
- I highly doubt it, but sure!
- In a world, where
testicles are served as food.
- Is this mashed balls?
- I'm used to, uh, heavier.
- Your . will never be the same again.
- It's really soft.
- I never thought I'd say this
but I like balls in my mouth.
- Testicles are the top two.
- Definitely the top two.
- Just like slipped right down.
- I've never seen a testicle
but I've surely eaten one.
- The moral of the story, skip the tongue,
go right to the balls.
- We've struggled really
hard to get away from our
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom image
but I swear this doesn't
happen on a day-to-day basis.
- I have this really bad
taste in my mouth right now.
- I'm surprised I haven't
thrown up on you yet.
- The olive oil was pretty disgusting.
- I liked all the dishes.
- It's the masala that kept it going.
- Would I have it again...?
Depends on how drunk I would be.
- This turned out to be a
less harrowing experience
than I thought it would be.
- Yeah that's true.